I would have loved to have worked at a
place like Groupon before before I
started Groupon and and and the reason
is it's it's a really helpful experience
in starting your company to have to have
been at a larger business so that you
can't anticipate some of the potential
pitfalls that you'll that you'll run
into or the what a company looks like
once it starts to scale most of what
I've learned about being in a larger
company I've learned from from my team
who's many of whom have come from larger
companies we have I'll give you one
example of a role at Groupon that's
that's attracted a lot of MBAs our city
manager position which is we've come in
and you run Chicago or you you you run
the daily deal business for New York New
York or something like that and Groupon
is unusual in the world of technology
companies because we're this cyborg
that's a combination of technology and
also humans we have a lot of people
calling merchants and doing doing manual
processes and that type of experience is
in invaluable leadership training it's a
it's a daily street fight going out
there and closing these in signing up
merchants I sometimes say at a company
like Google or Facebook everybody could
go home for four first six months or so
and the service would keep on running at
Groupon people could go home for five
days and we'd have to shut down like we
just have to put up a closed sign
because because our that that's about
how much lead time we have of merchants
that are actually scheduled to run on
the site so it's a it's intense it's
very operational you learn how to lead
people you learn how to work with
technologists and it's a great
leadership training ground for people
who are looking to go on and run
something or theirselves
you